yes ladies and gentlemen you read that
correctly spider Rex there is a story
that details the origin of spider Rex
and it is amazing
I love this story so here's the thing
here's the thing this is part of the new
edge of spider-verse and just when you
thought the Spiderman had encountered a
threat that would lay waste to the
spider-verse and change the landscape of
the Spider-Man Mythos forever here we go
again another one so here's the thing
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with this edge of spider-verse
originally got its starred as part of
the original spider-verse event and the
idea behind edge of spider-verse is that
it basically just told a series of small
stories inside of a larger comic quite
literally the edge of spider-verse
comics are basically what like Action
Comics was back in the 1940s when
Superman was first introduced or Marvel
Premiere or Marvel presents or any one
of those kind of stories it's an
anthology series and so what this does
is it basically picks up on Earth 66 and
we're just told it was a long long time
ago of course Earth 66 being an
alternate reality and what you end up
having going on here and it's actually
kind of funny is you basically have
spider Rex and you have what really just
looks like a pterodactyl version of the
Green Goblin who are effectively
fighting now it wasn't always this way
because what it does is it gives us a
flashback and it tells us at some
previous point in time you basically had
the pterodactyl who we can call Norman
Osborne by all intents and purposes in
this story right the Green Goblin but
basically you had Norman Osborne the
Green Goblin who was a Tyrannosaurus Rex
and you had Peter Parker who was
basically a pterodactyl and what ended
up happening is that as the two of them
were fighting and in fact Norman was
going to kill Peter Parker like
literally eat him Norman gets hit in the
face with a meteor that has spiders on
it radioactive spiders most likely and
the result is that not only does it
cause them to switch bodies they get
costumes because you know comic book
logic it doesn't have to make sense it's
not a real story so one of the things
that happens is that with them switching
bodies Peter Parker of course getting
his Spider-Man costume his spider X
costume ends up meeting with his Uncle
Ben and Aunt May who of course are
basically pterodactyls and they're kind
of like I mean it's okay you know it's
it's cool you turned into a giant you
know dinosaur that would consume us
under any normal circumstance and then
basically Norman goes back to his
henchmen which looked like Velociraptors
more than anything else and that's kind
of how things have been ever since and
so with the two of them basically
butting heads again it's kind of a funny
thing because unlike what you would
expect with there being some sort of
grand scheme the reality is that
Norman's just pissed because he doesn't
have his body anymore not only that
Peter's discovering his powers as he
does this right so check this out so
Peter Parker overcomes Norman by
basically slapping him into a tree and
then he webs up his henchmen I just want
to point out here in this story this is
a story it's gonna be a short video this
is a story where basically you have a
Spider-Man version of a Tyrannosaurus
Rex that's shooting webbings out of his
hands and I gotta be honest one part of
me looks at that and like this is
amazing and then another part of me
looks at it is like this is horrifying
because seeing a Tyrannosaurus Rex just
running down the road shooting webbing
hit people it sounds horrifying fine
right it sounds like something out of
the No Sleep subreddit but I kind of
want to see it happen at the same time
not only that he shoots his webbing into
a tree and swings away this is a
Tyrannosaurus Rex swinging away using
webbing now the crazy thing about this
is that of course Norman Osborne comes
chasing after him but because he shoots
his webbing into a branch the branch
isn't strong enough to hold him so
basically he falls down he lands on
Norman Osborne which basically seems to
kill Norman Osborne as well as a couple
of innocent dinosaurs and ultimately he
learns the lesson that with great power
must also come great responsibility and
that's the story that's literally it
I told you I love this story I love this
so much it's just it's so perfect right
it's just silly and goofy and perfect
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace